bonjour moins violent et bonne journée
en martinique 1 qui nous écoutent
membres de la section martiniquais des
républicains vous êtes avec nous au
lendemain de ce deuxième débat télévisé
avec cette fois-ci l'ensemble des
candidats à la présidentielle
gabriel l'encours comment avez vous
senti celui que vous défendez à savoir
françois fillon tout d'abord une idée
générale c'était très bien d'avoir le
panel des onze candidats à l'élection
présidentielle pour une fois on a
privilégié l'ensemble des candidats
plutôt que de sélectionner sur un
échantillon représentatif dit
représentatif
quelques candidats c'est un gros
avantage d'entendre cette remontée de
propositions émanant des différents
courants que représentent ces candidats
les cons veniant c'est que bien entendu
les questions de fond n'ont pas été
abordés j'en veux pour preuve les
questions de culture les questions de
tourisme les questions de développement
économique mais vraiment profonde et
leur accès
alors la guyane j'espère qu'on pourra
dire deux mots et puis la superficialité
quelquefois des interventions n'a pas
permis vraiment aux téléspectateurs
d'avoir une connaissance profonde du
rôle du président de la république ce
matin des observateurs de la vie
politique française la presse française
ne sont pas très tendres même avec
l'ancien premier ministre
la revue challenge dit par exemple qu'il
a dû subir françois fillon il a dû subir
visages fermés les attaques croisées de
ses concurrents sur les affaires et sur
la moralité de la vie politique c'est
normal parce que la droite et le centre
ne sont pas divisés
vous l'avez remarqué la gauche est
divisée ya plusieurs candidats qui
représente les tendances de gauche la
droite est seul en plus c'est vrai que
c'est un ancien premier ministre
et puis c'est le programme le plus le
plus solide le plus cohérent lors
forcément toutes les attaques convergent
vers lui et on essaie de à travers
vraiment seul contre 10 pas seul contre
10,6 présente il s'adresse à la
population française ils s'adressent à
bien entendu l'ensemble de la france et
des territoires d'outre-mer mais bien
entendu les attaques fossé font partie
du jeu de la compétition alors vu qu'il
est en si bonne position que ça il a il
a le mauvais siège celui du de la
troisième position pour l'instant il est
talonné françois fillion par jean luc
mélenchon et en attendaient justement au
vu des affaires au vu de de son bilan du
temps où elle était premier ministre et
sans cesse ressassée on attendait que ce
débat soit un véritable rebond pour lui
vous avez l'impression que ça a été le
cas
j'ai l'impression que de plus en plus
son programme devient audible
passée cette campagne de boules puantes
il devient maintenant aux dîmes parce
que les français attendre du futur haut
représentant de l'état nation un homme
premièrement cas du courage un homme qui
a de la volonté pour faire et enfin
quelqu'un qui a de l'expérience le
visage fermé hier
c'était quand même un peu sur eux alors
la scion d'abord si on aborde la
question des impressions on pourrait le
faire pressante des candidats il faut
être moi je veux qu'on rentre dans les
questions vraiment de faux et qu'on
puisse parler du rôle du président la
république et puis des questions qui
nous intéresse au niveau des
départements d'outre-mer
oui eh bien justement françois fillon
c'est quand même le candidat de ce celui
qui dit que on peut redresser et la
france qu'il a le moins de le faire
selon lui si le seul programme présenté
aux français qui pourrait le faire en se
basant essentiellement sur
l'investissement sur la production sur
les larmes sur la sueur il faudra serrer
la ceinture ce message est passé selon
vous hier soir où je ne pense pas que
son programme soit des larmes et de la
sueur
si on compare avec celui de françois
hollande qui quitte le gouvernement qui
quitte la présidence partant de la
république avec son gouvernement et qui
n'osent même pas se représenter devant
le suffrage universel
c'était justement d'élan mais des pleurs
c'est une augmentation des impôts ces
six millions et demi de chômeurs en
souricière traumatique sistema déficit
public soit une urbanisation thématique
de françois hollande
la reprise naissante de la france au
niveau du classement international on
est sixième pays aujourd'hui au lieu de
la cinquième place on a eu des
conséquences très graves de la politique
menée par françois hollande et on le
voit aujourd'hui pour la guyane qui
commence a réagi avec beaucoup de
raisons et de fermeté je soutiens
d'ailleurs et nous soutenons nous au
niveau du comité fillon le/la la
mobilisation du peuple guyanais qui a
ses devoirs
un fleuron de l'industrie aérospatiale
magot j22 aujourd'hui c'est blé réalité
pourquoi chaque fois quand on est
pragmatique on est démagogue
donc la réalité parce que là vous dire
il ya cinq ans il y a eu un peu ta
président ump républicaine que la
sarkozie avec une certaine force fillon
premier ministre
on a vu françois fillon venir en
marquant à percer quand les brisants il
ya dix ans on a vu comment il faut de la
signaler ce qui s'est passé pendant cinq
ans mais le bilan de françois hollande
on on ne fait que le mr ont pu faire
beaucoup et on fait beaucoup évolution
de sens cosy et de fignon mais personne
ne veut faire le bilan de françois
hollande pose c'est une question qui
fait appel bouxin de gras mais je penche
pour la guyane je vais vous dire une
chose et vous avez raison quand même de
dire que depuis des années on s'occupe
pas réellement des départements d'autres
mères que dirait que disait le général
de gaulle disait que la guyane c'est une
terre d'avenir et le restera cette
phrase m'a beaucoup interpellé
lorsque françois mitterrand avait
transféré les compétences certaines
compétences de l'état aux départements
d'outre-mer il l'a fait mais sans
rattraper les retards structurels qui a
fait on n'a jamais donné aux
départements d'outre-mer les moyens de
rattraper le roi temps et de rebondir
économiquement alors qu'est ce qu'il ya
dans le programme en 1900 euros
en attendant en 2014 rappelez vous que
ce qui s'est passé pour la bretagne a eu
un pacte d'avenir qui a été signé avec
les différents le préfet les différents
préfet d'ille-et-vilaine et de la
bretagne et les présidents de
collectivités territoriales de bretagne
ce pacte d'avenir a été chiffré à 2
milliards en un en 2014 en 2015
consécutivement à ce pacte d'avenir
qu'est ce qui a été signé un contrat et
appelant région a été signé pour un
montant de 1 milliard en deux pour
assurer justement le rebond économique
de la bretagne
lorsque vous avez une fusée ariane
question un territoire de 83 mille
kilomètres carrés
c'est à dire le double deuil du danemark
c'est un territoire aussi grand que
l'autriche ce territoire qui est deux
fois et demie plus grand que la belgique
et que vous avez un sous sol minier avec
de l'eau qui ne bénéficient pas aux
guyanais
c'est normal que ce peuple se mobilise
on a répété que la guyane c'est comme
l'afrique depuis l'afrique
jacques chirac auparavant valérie
giscard d'estaing le citer que ceux de
droite
un jour j'ai dit tous les autres pour
les gouvernements de droite et de gauche
et je vous ai cité monsieur mitterrand
qui est resté quatorze ans au pouvoir
c'est sur la 5ème république celui qui
est resté le plus longtemps et c'est lui
qui a transféré avec gaston defferre les
compétences de l'état aux régions
il ne l'a pas fait accompagnée des
moyens financiers aux secrets pour aider
les régions les régions des départements
d'outre-mer au réseau aujourd'hui de se
mobiliser et de réclame un pacte
d'avenir l'audace meilleurs qu'on a fait
une loi sur l'égalité réelle
oui peut-être mais seulement avec une
planification qui remonte aux agents
sien et qui ne vise pas l'efficience et
l'efficacité économique on attend
justement maintenant et tout à l'heure
de bain après demain qu'est ce qu'il ya
dans le programme de françois fillon qui
pourrait permettre à nos pays de
décoller investissements à tous crins
dans tous les domaines que ce soit le
btp le tourisme singulièrement le
tourisme et je voudrais dire deux mots
du tourisme les anglais
et françois fillon le prévoit d'ailleurs
dans son programme les défiscalisations
pour le tourisme et notamment les
engagements de l'administration fiscale
ne peuvent pas être prise au niveau
local avant d'en dans toutes les
demandes de déductions fiscales c'est
bercy qui vient se positionner et
tranchées et faire les arbitrages
françois fillon qu'est ce qu'ils
proposent que ces déductions fiscales
soit examiné au niveau local pour tous
les porteurs de projets pour tous les
projets de modernisation des équipements
touristiques entre ces millien entre 5
millions et 10 millions d'euros
aujourd'hui à peine plus un million et
demi d'euros c'est bercy qui tranche
donc ils kof il transfère cette
responsabilité aux collectivités locales
et c'est une excellente chose dans le
domaine de la culture
il propose de développer la culture des
départements d'outre-mer
ce qui n'a pas été dit dans le débat
justement les hier puisque effectivement
quand on a que 17 minutes pour
s'exprimer et contenus du panel de
candidats il est quand même difficile
d'abord d'aborder les questions dans le
fond en ce qui concerne par exemple
l'alternance pour la formation des
jeunes
le renforcement du r head du sm a pour
former des jeunes pour développer
l'apprentissage de manière leur
permettent de trouver un emploi cela est
dans le programme de françois fillon
s'est défaussé la santé non parlons en
long du domaine de la santé si on veut
pas parler du domaine de la formation
mais c'est capital parce que je suis la
première manche pour trouver un nom
c'est sûr que c'est la réponse au
chômage mettons en avant des questions
de santé et puisqu'aujourd'hui c'est un
sujet qui est quand même assez crucial
vous avez vu l'état de délabrement de
nos hôpitaux
mais françois fillon propose justement
et c'est lui qui avait mis en place les
agences régionales de santé je ne sais
pas si vous vous en souvenez et qui
avait associé aux agences
un jeune al de santé la partie médico
social il propose justement de
développer les ehpad de lutter contre
les déserts médicaux de mettre en place
des maisons médicales de garde ce qui
est déjà été fait depuis 2012 et de
renfoncer également le tissu de santé de
protection de la santé par des maisons
pluridisciplinaires
voilà des questions qui intéressent les
départements d'outre-mer quand on voit
leur les files d'attentes aux urgences
eh ben les maisons médicales de garde
les maisons pluridisciplinaires dans les
trois communes dans les villes qui sont
sous médicalisées 10e c'est quelque
chose d'interdît philo pu refaire son
retard dans les sondages
je ne crois pas aux sondages moi je dis
qu'il faut faire campagne il ya trois
semaines de campagne
il faut faire campagne il faut
convaincre que c'est le meilleur
programme
et c'est ce que nous allons faire au
niveau du comité fillon gabriela
concours soutien à françois fillon merci
d'avancé
nous sommes très bonne journée merci mot
idiot le temps
[Musique]